♪♪
-The [bleep] is you
supposed to be?
-Hi. I'm Stede.
-He's the Gentleman Pirate.
-Well, I got bad news for you,
genital pirate.
I'm about to start
a whole new nose jar.
-Uh, baby?
-Don't say that.
Don't call me that.
-Well, I just figured,
since we're married --
-None of my other husbands
have a problem with this.
-That's mine.
-Do not call me that in here.
-Okay. Well, you see,
Hans was in here
asking about him for his boss.
-Blackbeard?
Mother [bleep] Blackbeard
want to talk to this guy?
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
That was a clip
from the new comedy series
"Our Flag Means Death."
We're here talking
to Leslie Jones.
And are you enjoying
playing a pirate?
-Yes!
Are you kidding me?!
That's like giving candy
to a baby.
Are you serious?
First of all, they had me
a pirate and wooden hand,
and then they added on
I have 19 husbands.
What?
That is like my dream.
Hello!
[ Laughter ]
I just -- It was --
It was so --
And the director
was so good.
Like, for real, Seth.
Like, he pulled it out of me.
Like -- Like, you see --
You've never seen me that calm.
-No, that's true.
-You've never seen me that calm.
And I, like --
You know what he told me?
Which I love.
Him and David --
David Jenkins came up to me,
and they was just like,
"We are so excited
to have Leslie Jones here,
but we don't want
Leslie Jones on the screen.
We want Spanish Jackie."
And it was so fun for --
Ignacio would tell me,
he was like,
"You're Spanish Jackie.
Nobody --
You don't go to anyone.
Someone comes to you."
Like, it was so --
The direction was so good.
It was so good.
-And it's really fun.
There we see that Fred Armisen
is one of your 19 husbands.
It must've been fun
to work with Fred, as well.
-You know how crazy
Fred is, right?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Fred is so good
at what he does,
and he's so quick.
So we immediately
became like a real couple.
And, like -- we --
Like, it was like --
'Cause Fred was like
one of my favorite husbands.
He's around.
You know what I'm saying?
And he lets me do crazy stuff.
He lets me hurt him
and all of that.
Like, yeah.
He's my favorite husband.
Like, but I'm not gonna
let him know that.
And it's me and Fred just --
We're like -- I love him.
I love people who are quick.
Like you!
I love you.
That's why I love
interviewing with you.
'Cause you so quick.
-Yeah, but you love me,
and I can't even get one
of the 19 husband roles.
[ Laughter ]
Um, Seth, you are
gonna be president soon,
and you do not want the scandal
of being with me.
-Very kind of you to say.
Hey, um, I want --
We always talk about TV shows
you're enthusiastic about.
We have long been looking
for our next "Game of Thrones"
that we could watch together.
What are you watching right now?
Oh, my God!
Okay. So I'm watching "Bel Air."
You know the new "Bel Air"?
-Yeah.
-Oh, my gosh, Seth!
It's so good!
-Great.
-It's so good!
-"Station 11."
-"Station 11" -- great.
-So good!
So good. Okay?
So good.
Okay.
Make sure that you watch
"Legendary."
"Legendary" is on HBO Max, too.
-Okay.
-Of course, you know,
"Euphoria."
"Euphoria" is the worst version
of Charlie Brown I ever seen.
[ Laughter ]
Like, it's like --
Wait, no, we need
the "wah wah wah" in this.
Like, good God!
[ Laughter ]
It's --
I'm watching so many things.
I --
I'm just, like, tickled
with some of the stuff
that's coming out
because it's so good.
"Bel Air" -- so good.
Are you watching some adaptation
of "Anne of Green Gables"?
-What?
There's a -- What?
Wait a minute.
'Cause I love
"Anne of Green Gables" now.
I watched the new one.
There's another one?
-No, no, that's the one
I'm talking about.
Oh, is that the best show?
-I don't know.
I'm not watching it.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Then why did you ask me
about it, then?
Because I heard
that you had watched it,
and you're the guest.
[ Laughter ]
-No, "Anne of Green Gables,"
like, it's kind of --
You know, I've already seen it.
I mean, I'm pretty sure
everyone --
I don't know
why you brought that up,
but, yeah,
we could talk about it.
Like, it's really good.
It's a very good remake
of the original.
-Okay.
-"Anne of Green Gables."
That girl is so perfect
for that role.
I love her.
-All right, great.
So which one should
we watch together?
'Cause I haven't seen --
What --
I mean, I feel like "Euphoria"
would be fun to watch together.
Should we do that?
-Oh, my God.
Have you watched it, Seth?
-I haven't watched a lot of it.
-Oh, Seth, that's the new
"Game of Thrones" for us.
-Yeah.
-That's it.
-Yes, that's it.
Oh, my God!
-I feel like it's like...
a real life "Game of Thrones"
and how shocking it is.
-Dude, I...
That is --
That is the best idea.
But, look, we got to start
from season one, though.
-Great.
-Oh, my God.
That makes me excited.
You know I'm crazy.
[ Laughter ]
And you gotta love
yelling at the TV.
-I mean, this is --
I feel like this
would be really fun.
So here's the deal.
The next time you come out here,
we'll do, like, a test run.
We'll do a pilot of --
-Let's do a couple of them
since we gonna do season one
'cause we got to do a wrap --
-Yeah.
-Oh, my God!
That sounds so good!
[ Laughter ]
-All right. Here we go.
We figured it out together.
Hey, Leslie, as always,
I love seeing you.
I love you very much.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you, baby.
You know, I miss you so much.
-I miss you, too.
I'm gonna get you out here.
Leslie Jones, everybody!
"Our Flag Means Death"
streams on HBO Max
with new episodes
every Thursday.